the evangel living is a lifestyle
you see in the early church they just
live their lives and people say wow
there's something different about that
person and so we don't need more
evangelism we need more evangel living
we've seen the problems in the world and
the church seems to have the answers but
how effective has the church been in
solving the world's problems find out on
this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at led live again if you
didn't see the last show we did with
london you might want to check that out
now but he's going to give a little bit
of a recap we're basically talking about
the world's problems the world seems
like it's falling apart at the seams and
it seems like
no man
has any answers so we're looking at
where who has the answers and we decided
that it should be the bible it should be
the church which is not a building but a
body of believers so we got london again
here and tell us a little bit a little
bit about your ministry and how people
can find more of your resources all
right so our ministry is ten talents
international and our focus is training
ambassadors for christ
we need more people boots on the ground
we have a lot of preachers but we need a
lot of livers you know people who are
going to live out the gospel and so you
can go to t-e-n-talents.org
also
our mission our desires to equip and
train ordinary people like you to become
extraordinary servants in the
proclamation of the everlasting gospel
and we do that one person at a time and
so we also have a website it's a
resource it's 10 times wiser.com and
there we have classes that people can
can take and so we have cooking classes
we have classes on prayer on how to
share your faith on
how to monetize your skills and mental
health we have many different classes
there and that also supports our
ministry and so that's a little bit
about us and we're just excited to share
with you guys awesome man well last last
time we did this with you was really eye
opening so i'm i'm ready to hear what
the remedy is and if the church is doing
what they need to do all right so in our
last session we talked about man's
problem and
god's solution god's remedy we've seen
that the world is in a crisis we've seen
that every remedy that man has tried has
proved a failure we've asked the
question are we happy with the results
and we had a resounding no and so we see
the pollution we see the corruption we
see all this so the question is what is
the remedy you see the gospel of jesus
christ is the remedy whether people know
it or not the people that are looking
for this thing to solve their problem
whether it be mental or physical or
spiritual emotional social the bible is
the answer and so we believe that the
christianity of christ
is the only hope for humanity and so we
looked at this verse in the book of
revelation it says here is the patience
of the saints here are they that keep
the commandments of god and the faith of
jesus this is where we get our title for
our series what's the difference between
faith in jesus and faith of jesus and so
we notice that this group of people they
have they keep the commandments of god
they have the faith of jesus and so we
asked the question well where did these
commandments come from do you remember
where who from god's own finger
is god's work
and guess what it was written by the
finger of god and so we know the story
that god gave moses right he wrote it
with his own figure and so notice where
revelation 14 14 says
so it says it's talking about this
harvest right there's going to come a
harvest where god is going to come and
harvest uh it says before that though
there is a last warning message so
before the lord comes to harvest
he's going to send a message isn't god
merciful amen before judgment there is
always mercy right just like with jonah
go go tell nineveh that there's a
judgment coming yeah i preached to him
noah preached to these people for 120
years long suffering man right god is so
good so always sends a warning before so
in the bible the three angels messages
these are the last warning message to a
dying planet so now the result of this
message is seen in the company who keep
the commandments of god and have the
faith of jesus so god sends out a
warning through these three angels and
then the people who accept this warming
they begin to keep the commandments of
god and they have not just faith in
jesus but literally the faith of jesus i
have a question you may address it but
just for people that that word angels
are you going to talk about that well
the angel is angelos which is a
messenger which can mean preachers
preachers uh teachers teachers prophets
whatever right and so an angel is a
messenger so god's going to get this
message out maybe not through an angelic
being no sounding a trumpet but church
that's right those messengers we have
the remnants so we also looked at
ephesians 4 4 and 5 where it talks about
one body one spirit one hope one lord
one faith one baptism one god and father
and this one church is going to have the
remedy and so
the faith of jesus for our purposes we
need to study the life of christ we need
to study what is it that's going to
bring the remedy to the world and so
today we're going to look at the
challenge what is the challenge to the
world the church claims to have the
answers to life's biggest questions so
how has the church done with
administering the remedy we claim to
have and so
we look at the church jesus says for
they keep what the commandments of god
and have the faith of jesus so what was
jesus last commandment to his church
because it says this group of people
they keep the commandments of god so
question is what was jesus last
commandment then he say
go and teach and make disciples he said
all power in heaven and earth is
delivered unto me therefore brittany
therefore mikey alex london you and me
go and teach preach so notice let's look
at this this is matthew 28 verse 18.
disciples it says and jesus came and
spake unto them saying all power in
heaven or our power is given unto me in
heaven and in earth
therefore now usually we start this
sentence with the go
right right go and teach and preach and
baptize but the the the prerequisite to
going is having all power
so when we are walking with jesus when
we have the faith of jesus i can walk
boldly i can walk with in in assurance
that guess what the almighty god is on
my side amen so it says teach right
teaching it says baptizing them in the
name of the father the son and the holy
ghost and it also says teaching notice
it says teaching twice
so the church is supposed to be a place
where people could come and learn
right jesus says come unto me and learn
of me but oftentimes
church becomes a place where people just
consume or just download it the preacher
comes opens up their mind here this is
what
right right and people don't know who
they believe they may no they might know
what yeah but they might not know the
who
yeah you're right like teaching i i
think of somebody being like okay let me
show you how to study this
find it here it's also going to be found
here but instead it's just like this is
what it says no need to turn in your
bibles i'm just going to keep telling
you right so here it says teaching them
how many things
all things all things whatsoever i have
what commanded you so notice teaching
them to observe teaching them to keep
teaching them to live out the principles
that god
is commanding us to do he says and lo i
am with you sometimes no i'm with you
when you do good
or they say i am with you what always
always even unto what the end of the
world and many people are talking about
the end of the world is here right yeah
and many people are fearful even in the
church but we forget that jesus says i
will be with you even unto the end and
so the the faith of jesus we we realized
that this church that has the faith of
jesus they're going to be missionary
church teachers yeah right they're going
to be going out to the highways and to
the hedges they're not just going to be
cloistered up in their little
communities no they're going to be out
sharing number two we learn this church
will teach people to observe how many
things all things all things that jesus
taught and that jesus lived that's why
it's called the faith of jesus because
you can have the faith of so and so in
the faith of this person but what is
what is it that jesus taught and most
importantly was it that he lived and so
this church his mission is to
live
i didn't say evangelica i did that on
purpose because
evangelism is usually a process you
bring in a speaker you bring in bible
workers you bring but evangel living is
a lifestyle wow you see in the early
church they just live their lives and
people say wow there's something
different about that person and so we
don't need more evangelism we need more
evangel living so
where can we find this church what do
you think who where where do we find
this church that is so on fire for the
lord what do you think
would you like to know yeah like that
all right here we go the only way this
can happen is the unity of all true
christians so question why is it
important for all of christianity to
come together all true christians to
come together what do you think why do
you think that's important
to reflect uh god's uh character okay
that is love his glory his glory okay
yeah i think it sounds like a a
beautiful world if we all
agree to live by god's principles love
your neighbor love him
what could go wrong yeah and i think god
is also a god of order
so
and unity is um
is a character trait of god disorder is
of the enemy so
all right so the three angels message
actually is the thing that's going to
bring that unity this and i saw another
angel flying in the midst of heaven
having what the everlasting everlasting
gospel to what preached preach
right to unto them that dwell on the
earth to who to every nation kindred
tongue and people saying with a small
voice
that word uh loud is the word megaphone
what english word does that sound like
megaphone so this is not like jesus
loves you the end is coming i don't want
to offend you no this is you're going to
the end
right so it's a megaphone and what's the
message fear god and give glory to him
why for the hour of his judgment has
come and worship him that made the
heavens the earth the sea and the
fountains of the water so the the
message that brings about the unity is
called the everlasting gospel now i have
this thing that i've done all over the
world i have a quick question for you i
want you to tell me what the gospel is i
want you to give me one verse and you
cannot use john 3 6.
i was about to say it
so so give me a text just you can just
quote it what is the gospel it has to be
a scripture and it has to be a scripture
because we're bible believers right
right give me a scripture i could
summarize it okay summarize somewhat
i mean we have a loving god that created
us and he wants to
have true friendship with us and
we failed and he he sent a savior which
was his son to die for us and
mikey that's too long yeah
i know i lost my tick tock crew right
there
so okay so so a scripture just one
scripture that encapsulates the gospel
your faith just think about what's your
favorite scripture and you at home
what's your favorite scripture if you
had if you had one text to share with
somebody to share the gospel with him
what text would you use and it can't be
john 3 16. okay i'm going to shoot my
shot here
i know
in the beginning of my walk of faith
my favorite was jeremiah 29 11. oh okay
can you and how that would relate to the
gospel is that um what does it say
for i know the plans i have for you
declares the lord plans not to harm you
but to give you hope and a future okay
so why is that good news to you because
in spite of all the bad things that are
happening no matter how sinful that i
may have been god still has good plans
for me like there's a hope to look
forward to
um so you don't have to fear the future
right because god he has it
exactly all right so you were asking us
what is the definition of the gospel uh
finding in the scripture
okay so i found it i know english is my
second language right so when i hear uh
anything and anywhere like it is
it's kind of like it's going to be
describing something or definition right
defining it yes so in romans
uh chapter
1 verse 16 verse 16. uh we found there
it says i'm going to read it they say
for i am not ashamed of the gospel of
christ because
it is it is the power of god to
salvation to everyone
who believes for the jews first and also
greek and stuff like that so to me when
i said the definition of biblical
definition is it is the power
salvation okay so the question is for
what what's salvation for what from our
sense okay from our sense no anger sense
okay so
you're 100
correct almost saved by grace it says
i am not ashamed of the gospel of
jesus christ jesus is the gospel mm-hmm
you see it so jesus jesus is the gospel
and he's also the power of god
so if the church
is to reach the world with the gospel
the only way we can do that is if we are
connected to
jesus jesus christ right so so that's
the remedy okay jesus is the remedy okay
so putting aside petty differences and
disputes so you look at the world today
look at the world it's it's in disarray
it's falling apart what about the
christian world right
to show the world
the power of the gospel there must be
unity in the church to save and to
change lives the church has to have that
power right so when we look at the world
and we look at the church see this is
the challenge of the church
it's not doctrinal
it's not informational we have
christians don't need more information
do we
right we need
a application that will lead to a
transformation and then and only then
there can be a what a demonstration so
we are not united would you agree with
that christianity and christians are not
united
look at the numerous conflicting
denominations of christianity all
claiming to follow who jesus jesus we
all have the same bible we all have the
same access to the information but guess
what when they come to their conclusions
they're
what fractured and so the atheist looks
at the christian world and says you guys
are just as confused as me right the
agnostic and and the the punk rocker and
the hip-hopper you put whatever type of
person and they look at the church and
they say every man is doing that which
is in his own right in his own eyes and
so all claiming to have what faith
in jesus you go to a baptist oh i i love
jesus you go to a penalty called anyone
an adventist or whatever and you say do
you love g do you have faith in jesus
they say yes i have faith in jesus he's
my personal lord and savior he's coming
to say now what is the faith of jesus
is there a difference
so why is there no unity in the church
then
what is the problem and why don't all
christians walk together what do you
guys think can two walk together unless
they be
agreed amos 3 3. i think we got an enemy
that's been
working really hard and
causing division because he knows that
we are
we are the answer to
the ones that we're the ones that are
pointing people to christ to the answer
and if he can
just disrupt that then
he's
he's making an accomplishment okay so
what type of food do you like
oh pasta pasta what type of food do you
like uh
vegetarian sushi sushi okay what do you
like mexican mexican i like thai
so if we all wanted to go out to our
favorite restaurants
and we all like different foods
how would that night out on the town
work
compromise
what'd you say compromise compromise
yeah that's the key word you see
oftentimes christians compromise
the truth because hey well she likes
this and he likes that so we'll
compromise because you right that's why
the bible says can two walk together
unless they be what agree right so the
the the because we are disagreed
because we are not in unity there's no
power because that's what the gospel is
the power to change the life
examples of challenges we face so the
bible says go every nation kindred
tongue and people i was a missionary in
japan as i said earlier and so this was
me i taught english
and i love japan i love my time i spent
four years there i met my wife there uh
this was us we taught in i taught in
osaka and in hiroshima and they're in
japan there's
150 million people and one percent of
that population is christian
so that shows you the the the importance
of being united right and there were
other missionaries from other uh
denominations and affiliations and we
were all there and we were we would go
out we'd go on prayer walks we would go
around the city because there was uh sex
trafficking was huge in the city that we
lived in osaka and we would have prayer
walks we were fast and one day we
decided that we should come into
agreement and see
what you believe versus what you believe
and what we believe and we sat down and
for three hours
wow we found out that there was no
agreement
because they thought this and i thought
that and this and so
there was disunity and guess what
happened to our ministry fell apart it
fell apart we had to go our own separate
ways because there was
disagreement
so this is the challenge so
notice what do you think about the
church
so i tell you this story so imagine an
alien you just did this amazing
documentary aliens right so imagine an
alien came from an outer space and they
come to the church right and you say you
asked them the question what do you
think about the church
and they say well what church
and you say the christian church
and
they say you mean to tell me
that this com this conflicting body of
christians makes up the church
you you do you do they all claim to
follow jesus do all churches claim to
follow jesus right the baptist the
presbyterian right okay do they all call
him master yeah you would have to say
yes yes we all call him master okay do
they all read the same bible
yeah they might have niv kjv whatever
but basically it's the same right and
then they would say why do they all walk
separately
how would you enter this this being from
an outer
space how would you answer that question
why is it that we all have the same
access to everything but yet we are not
united i guess i mean the only logical
thing is some people are interpreting
this differently than me or something
okay i i think one thing that i've um
always struggled with my whole life i
got to a point where i was like am i
really following jesus or just my idea
of him because i noticed that a lot of
things in my like i would just try to
shape jesus into what i wanted him to be
like so that i can stay the way that i
was
and yeah it's just
see that's faith in jesus
not the faith
of jesus right so we all have access to
the same material so why do they not
walk unitedly you see the bible says can
two walk together unless they be what
agreed so let's look at some examples of
how
the the the secular pagan heathen world
is confused when it comes to the doors
of the church so when you come to the
bible different churches teach different
things about the bible some say it's
historically true some say it's myth
allegories and fables some say the new
testament is all that you need today
some say no no you need the both the new
and the old right when it comes to
baptism some people say no you have to
be by baptized by immersion some say no
no it's good enough just to sprinkle
others say no it's only the holy spirit
that you need what about prophecy what
are some things that people believe
about prophecy they say are you
post-tribulation or are you
pre-tribulation are you no tribulation
right some people believe there's no
tribulation
there's historicism then there's
preterism when it comes to suffering
what are some different views on
suffering and christianity they don't
want to there are some people that don't
want to believe about suffering god does
does not allow suffering god does not
condem god does not destroy god
so you come and you're trying to teach
them and they go to this person that
pastor this and there's what
confusion
have you ever had somebody try to
explain something to you and you're like
what in the world
and what do you do with that person
click you're right yeah you turn them
off right right and so this is why
the the the atheist is not interested in
the remedy
that we claim to have so what about the
day of worship some say no sunday's the
day of worship some say no it's saturday
some say any day
it doesn't matter you choose right what
about salvation
what are the different views on how
you're saved what do you think what are
some things you've heard uh
maybe you're saved by your own works
okay or are you saved by faith alone
okay
yeah you can seek you can find god
inward right or once you're saved you're
always saying it's a guarantee all you
got to do is
believe in
jesus right so the church preaches unity
but what does the church live wow
do you see the problem yeah you see the
challenge that we have as christians
right and so the church is divided right
you have all these there's there's
conflict and so this is the cause of the
lack of success and power to take the
gospel to of jesus to the world that
needs jesus so much what do you all
think what's your feedback so far
i agree how's it gonna happen ah how's
it gonna happen right so matthew 28 19
says to take it to every nation kendrick
people right so god's love for the lost
we have to understand what is god's love
for the law is g is this jesus's plan
for his church notice let's go to the
bible we're going to go to john 17 verse
22. mikey would you read this for us
yeah
that they all may be one so jesus is
praying
he's in he's about to go to the cross
right and this is his last
dying wish
and he was like father
i want them all to be what
one
would you continue as as thou father are
in me
and i in thee that they are that they
also may be one in us so where is unity
in
jesus in jesus
not in your denomination or your
affiliation the unity is in jesus right
and so why
is there so many churches there why so
many denominations right notice it says
that the world what may believe that
thou art so when will the world believe
that jesus is real
that the gospel changes
when they see the power i guess when the
church that's united is united in jesus
so if you were the devil
what would you not want right unity you
would not or you would bring about a
false
unity yeah right prophecy speaks that
there's the world is going to come
together and guess what we see it
happening today the world is coming
together they're rallying behind this
coven and the jab and all the and
politically and economically and
socially and the religions are coming
together but are they coming together in
the faith of jesus or just claiming
faith in jesus right so notice and the
glory which thou has gave us me i have
given them that they may be one even as
we are one so notice the unity that
jesus is praying for i in them and thou
in me that they may be made what perfect
so how do you become perfect
only with christ's indwelling the holy
spirit walking through you
unity to christ right it says in the
world may know that thou has sent me so
now we're going to jump and we're going
to look at uh john 14 verse 4 through 6.
jesus is talking
and
brittany would you read this for us and
whether i go ye no and the way ye know
all right so jesus says
you need to know the way who's the way
jesus says i am the what way the truth
and the light thomas said unto him lord
we know not whether our goal is and so
why is
thomas called the doubting thomas why is
he called the doubter
because he didn't know whether jesus was
the son of god
and he wanted what
evidence he wanted evidence does the
world look for evidence yeah absolutely
we live in a scientific age
they don't want pie in the sky
they don't want they want what's the
evidence brittany what's the evidence
london and the evidence is to be seen in
the changed life right yeah so thomas
was a young man who followed jesus yet
like many followers today he was
confused right he didn't know is this
real and so he was confused about what
you see the conflicting teachings of the
pharisees the sadducees the herodians
the essenes they're like the
denominations today right right you go
over to the pharisees they believe in a
resurrection you go over to the
sadducees they don't believe and so
there's confusion right so the different
schools of religious thought brings
about confusion right so the lifestyle
was different the attitudes were
different the doctrines were different
so listen to his questions
how can we know the way
why is that a significant question
maybe that's like just
a question that we all at some point ask
and the answer is already here
right and and the world has many ways
right some people say all the ways lead
to salvation right right or the same god
or the same god right all roads leads
you know so notice it's important that
we understand not our way
but his way right so notice jesus says
let not your heart be troubled he says
you believe in god believe also in me he
says in my father's house are many
mansions and if it were not so i would
have told you and what do you say i go
to watch prepare prepare a place for who
for you
and he says and if i go and prepare a
place for you i will what come again so
what is the assurance that that jesus is
giving to the disciples we will be
united with him again i'm coming again
i'm coming again right and so
how long has the church been preaching
jesus is coming again
since that day since he left
and so people are saying like man you've
been the church has been saying jesus is
coming
for 2 000 years
do you think people are tired of hearing
about jesus coming yeah
right
and so people are tired of hearing
they're waiting for a revelation of
jesus christ right and receive you to
myself that where i am you may be also
so his question was
what is the way notice jesus's answer
jesus saith unto him i am the what the
way i am the way
i am the one true and i am the light of
life so there's three things that jesus
says that he is he's the way to
salvation he's the way to truth he's the
way to not only just life but eternal
life
so if you are confused like thomas
ask the lord which way right
he's the way he's the truth he's the
light if you are anxious
to know and to find the truth jesus says
what is the truth i'm the truth if you
uh if you're saying lord help me to find
the life like yours jesus says what
i am the life
so no man comes to the father but by me
so jesus is the answer so we've
discovered so far that what's the remedy
to the world's problem jesus jesus and
who has that remedy the church the
church
how effective has the church been
not the best we have not been effective
and so we need to move forward and say
okay how are we going to get to where
god wants us to be you know people are
studying people are hurting people watch
this channel because you guys are giving
them real solutions right you're dealing
with real issues right and so as we
study the word as we
look at uh the word of god as we look at
ourselves then we can come to this what
do you think about this picture
looks like he's
not wanting to hear the truth hiding
bearing his hand oh it's a phone it's a
phone oh yeah yeah yeah
so he's burying his head into a false
reality escapism but but
it
we are immersed in our technology right
right and so that's why i love what you
guys do cause you are where the people
are right the mass majority of people
are not gonna come to our churches
especially now with the pandemic
churches are shut down so how do we get
this message out right yeah how do we
deal with those who are hurting how do
we deal with those who are in pain right
those who are suffering those who are
are dealing with death and despair right
some people are living pie in the sky
right jesus is the answer
i will not what he says i will not what
leave you
alone he says i will not leave you
without a shepherd i will leave you i
will not lead you astray so let's look
at john uh 13.
john 13 verse 15. uh alex would you read
that for us sure uh for i have given you
an example so who's speaking
jesus
so jesus says i have given you an
example so am i your example no it's
your pastor example
no
is the pope the example
jesus christ so jesus so for the
christian
the only example i have is jesus would
you continue please that ye shall do as
i have done to you oh so what does he
say
do
as i have done
right so many christians are doing what
so-and-so did and so let's look at some
history so when you come to theology do
you do you know any any of who these
people are
as this martin luther here martin luther
okay uh like
tyndale or calvin
right you have all these great
theologians look at this is the
christian family tree wow this is what
christianity look now you have the
western church the eastern church you
have the radical church the anabaptist
you have all these different
denominations but if you go back to the
root who's the root of the church jesus
and we're supposed to follow who jesus
jesus and the apost how do you think the
church got to be
so fractured disagreement disagreement
right so notice some christians say i'm
a calvinist
right who was a french theologian so i
follow
calvin right he has a set of doctrine
some say i'm a wesleyan
right
methodist
right then some people say hey i follow
this guy or i'm a lutheran
right that's where the lutheran church
comes some say uh wetfield who's the
orthodox presbyterian church right some
say i'm catholic
i follow the pope and the priest and the
prelates right some even say hey i'm i
follow mary she's supposed to be the
co-mediatrix right
some say i follow olstein right
the non-denominational route right and
some say i'm pentecostal right
so
notice no man what
cometh unto the father but by me wait so
what does that mean
concerning the christian church
not by
luther
i mean he did amazing things for the
church right the whole reformation came
but but i'm not a lutheran
oh
what about the anabaptists right who do
we follow as christians jesus christ
jesus christ he says no man comes to the
father but by
me is it possible that you and i
are following men
rather than following the man wow
i think that's such an important point
because often times when people are
especially newcomers are driven away
from the church
they always say like you know the people
in the church treated me this way
hypocrites they don't look at jesus
himself you know like i don't think
we as imperfect human beings will ever
fully
um
we're not the standard yes exactly we're
not the standard and we're always
learning and growing and we are not
jesus christ you know
so that's why it's pivotal to make a
distinction between having faith in
jesus and the faith of jesus how was
jesus treated by the church by the way
by the theologians oh yeah they hated
him they hated him
right in his own home so if we look at
the life of jesus
they hated him but did he turn from the
father's love did he say i'm gonna leave
the church because it's a bunch of
hypocrites no he he says i must be about
my father's business right so no man
comes to the father but by me so
revelation is actually a revelation of
who
jesus christ but what about the beasts
and the the the all of that stuff
well sometimes the church is very
focused about you know all the bees and
babies mark of the bees and all the
stuff but they forgot about the author
of the book right and they whose kind of
salvation that's jesus christ so right
there's no salvation in any other name
other than christ right that's the
biblical so let's look at this uh now
we're in revelation 14 the beginning
right so it says i looked and lo a lamb
who's the lamb jesus stood on mount zion
and with him how many people
a hundred and forty four thousand having
the father's name
name now what is the word the word name
is character yeah so this group of
people has god's character and it's
written where in the beliefs of their
mind in the beliefs is there a war on
our mind yeah you know media is the
medium in which the devil is attacking
people's minds right it says and i heard
a voice from heaven as the voice of many
waters and as the voice of great thunder
and i heard notice he this is very
audible it's total sensory i heard the
voice of harper's harping with their
harps and they sung as it were a new
song before the throne and before the
four beasts and the elders and no man
could what learn that song
but the 144 000 which were what redeemed
from the earth these are they which were
not what
defiled with women
and they were what virgins what's a
virgin
pure pure right
these are they which follow the lamb so
who are they following jesus
all right so who are we to follow jesus
jesus wherever he goes these were
redeemed from among men being the first
fruit unto god and unto the lamb would
you read brittany
right
and i looked and lo a lamp stood on the
mouse zion and with him 140 and 4 000
having his father's name written in
their foreheads this is important
because whoever makes it there the only
way they're going to make it there is by
following jesus that's the point okay
and so
the question i have for your audience
for us are you following the lamb
or are you following
the lie
good question you see many people
believe they're following the lamb but
actually they're believing lies and so
jesus says i am the what
the door
by me if any man enter in he shall be
what saved and shall go in and out and
find pasture
now notice what the thief comes to do
what does the thief come to do
steal
kill
and destroy
i have come that they may have life and
that they may have it what more
abundantly so in the church
should be a group of people who are
living abundantly
but when we look at the church today
what do we see do we see abundance wow
we see infighting we see disagreement we
see all these different things
and so if we're going to actually come
to that point
where we can be unified again i'm
hammering this home for a reason
the only unity we're going to find is in
jesus christ it's his very faith i just
said hey man i was agreeing what she
said earlier you know somebody says
they're hurt by the church and they
leave the church instead of saying i
want to know you more lord and go
straight to the source
don't judge god by the way
the
his representatives act you know and and
church abuse is real right right church
abuse is real
but what if you know jesus says if i if
i be lifted up right i will draw and so
when we take our focus off of jesus and
we put it on anything or anyone else
we're bound to be disappointed because
man has failed right so i have a quick
question yes so do you think it is ever
necessary to remove yourself from
a church
to i guess
because jesus was not among the um
pharisees right i mean he would go and
teach sometimes but he couldn't be a
part of that they would not allow him so
in order to fully do what god wanted him
to do he did it
outside right but he he he still and
we're going to find this he was in the
church every sabbath where was he right
and the time he was in the synagogue
right
and so
notice jesus never tried to change the
structure
he was trying to change human hearts
because that's the root of the problem
right the wicked deceitful human heart
and so many people want to change the
structure
but jesus was focused on the root of the
problem which was the human heart wow
and so i believe that we need to stay
and be examples
of of what a christian is and what a
christian does and how a christian lives
if we leave the church and who's going
to be the witness right right if you
want to see change you've got to look in
the mirrors right with you right so
jesus's message is come follow me so
here we've seen that the church has the
solution
for the world's problems but we have to
understand okay now
how do does the church apply that so our
next session is going to be jesus's love
for man see that's the only thing that's
going to change
jesus says if you love me what keep my
commandments right
and so love is the most powerful thing
in the universe and many people are
looking for love in all the wrong places
right
and so i'm super excited to be able to
share with you and your audience and
that that god's love for man is the most
powerful thing this is the remedy to
your problem this is a remedy to your
family this is really really to any
difficulty you have whether it be mental
physical spiritual emotional it does not
matter jesus is the remedy amen did
anybody have any thoughts or questions i
wanted to ask no i mean it's just really
neat topic you know sometimes we don't
think about it like
you know i mean the problem remember the
remedy or something like that but
we need to be united and they united is
just through jesus christ as an example
because god is love so we need to the
drive was to keep going it's god's love
because if i'm saying like hey you know
what
they lost i mean i'm out of here right
so we need to come over here with
with keep going and every day we we
spend time with jesus that's the image
of god right
and surrender
like you were saying the root is in our
hearts right you know because let me
tell you uh when sin show up in this the
world i mean that's ego
that's self
so
i mean
you were talking about like
jesus is like no we i need to change
your heart because it's a rock
you know i'm going to give you i need to
give you a good heart with the good
feelings
and the thing is that how we're going to
how he's going to change that new heart
in hebrew says
i want to write my my beautiful law
right
and a new heart right my law and your
mind right so of course you were talking
about
you know media and all the stuff the
enemy knows i'm gonna mess around with
the media because they're very connected
like the picture of the guy
yeah
rewrite that's right our hard drive yeah
there's a quote that i love it says for
thousands of years satan has studied the
minds of men and he's learned to know it
well
in these last days he seeks to so
influence the minds man that none but
his voice may be heard wow wow so think
about it you think you're thinking your
own thoughts but it's the thoughts of
yeah
gates it's the thoughts of lebron it's
the thoughts of
cardi b it's the cards you know you name
them and so people are not even thinking
their own thoughts they dress the way
they dress because their favorite artist
or musician or whatever but true
identity true freedom in christ
is being comfortable in him yeah and the
thing is that when you when we have
those those thoughts it's not according
to god's will
let me tell you that's a demon talking
to you right you know and then you say
oh betty i think that sounds good right
oh
nice
justifying right it's just justified you
know so i'm very excited to go to the
next topic because i'm like man what is
what is the next what are you going to
be answer so thanks so much for sharing
thank you for having me yeah
personalities are contagious you know
the bible talks about you hang around
with fools you become a fool and so if
we ourselves if we want to see change in
society change in the world
we have to work on ourselves the closer
we get to god the closer we connect with
him and and start living that out in the
world we can be the salt we can be the
light
salt is addictive right you hang around
people they're like man you're salty bro
i want to be around you more like i feel
good i'm around you light reflects
things you know it hits that wall and it
reflects back we can be that way in the
community right so if we
follow jesus we
get the father's name and our character
the character in our minds
then we can help change the world man
and and we
the more we hang around
fellow believers and and all of us just
grow
i believe we can see positive change in
the world amen yeah where can people
find more of your stuff we said at the
beginning but did you have something
yeah i just you know talk about you know
be a lighting everything and we talk
about love right love life sharing and
one thing that i'm very passionate
and you know share truth you know share
the bible share the gospel right
but the question is how are you going to
share it
and what you were saying about you know
let's be light and jesus is our example
right and we talk about love
if we don't share
truth
bible
jesus you know god you know the whole
bible with love we fail come on
i mean i'm sorry yeah if we don't
right because if we grab the bible and
we're just like hey you didn't do that
you're wrong and you're the thing i'm
better than you or whatever you know my
church is good or i i know more
knowledge about you or i got this and
you don't have that and all stuff we
felt right i mean i'm sorry but that's
as we love and caring and let me tell
you even um
i'm sure you know you guys know
christianity is like baby christians
right
it's like it's like a little plant
you see a little plant it's like i'm a
christian and you think okay you need to
know all this
i mean put a little plant like you know
right right and it's like pouring a
bucket of water on a plant and i'm
drowning that's right so let me tell you
one uh you know i'm sure you guys know
that even jesus you know uh talked about
a story about
a lot about about guarding right now
right in this patient that little plan
is gonna be a huge
in a tree right
it takes time it's a process a process
and you need to take care of that with
water with sunlight all the stuff
and then the whole focus about the tree
guess what
five years or ten years you're gonna see
the fruit
so the little plants aren't gonna see
the fruit until later on that's a great
segue into our next all right
we're gonna see how did jesus connect
with people amen how did he help them to
grow in this process of becoming
followers of him amen so you asked the
question yeah people are confident yeah
in our ministry so you can go to www.ten
talents.org you can also uh go to
10 times wiser.com
there we have on-demand classes uh for
you and uh if you watch to the very end
we have something very special just for
the led live audience so keep watching
and there's something special for you
awesome well man thank you for sharing
that with us i'm excited to keep doing
these studies i'm really learning a lot
and i think it's cool that people can go
to your resources and and study for
themselves to show that own selves
approved without having to just watch
our show thank you for being with us
this week if you were blessed please let
us know below if you disagree or
whatever just leave a comment we'd love
to interact with you guys we we like to
engage with you guys more so than just
having you watch our videos we want to
actually get to know you and and study
with you and iron sharpens iron so if
you were blessed by this don't forget to
like it share it with your family and
friends and if you're not a subscriber
go ahead and subscribe so we can see you
next week on led live by you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it i mean i can't watch enough of
this the duelist who they say can speak
with the spirits the sins will destroy
the commandments forever a suspicious
list of names prompts an investigation
at a local school and concern from
parents the death note is derived from a
japanese animated show the girl told
authorities she got the idea from a
cartoon network show
mom
i recognize that voice anywhere
[Applause]
[Music]
you